aucun instant tokyo puisque c'est
maintenant la fin d'émission
je crois que j'ai oublié personne michel
serrault et venues
il est quand même venu dernier il est
quand même venu il est quand même venu
mais je veux vous avez trouvé la tenue
quoi alors finalement je pense et quand
finalement c'est une tenue correcte
oui c'est quand il y en a pour tout le
monde et j'ai gardé le papillon de
livres à puyoô mes chaussettes du choc
et c'est tout et puis finalement on m'a
pris c'est bien je m'attendais à tout
sauf à ça vous est venu c'est gentil
c'est vrai parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
prévenus
ah non là vraiment je suis plus en plus
étonné qu'elle était comme ça ils font
ça et souvent
et puis ensuite il se et vous ayez vu
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure l'exhibition
que tout à fait extraordinaire je donne
tout et tous les commentaires que vous
voulez c'est parti je moi je non non non
du monde quand même est-ce que vous
pensez alors de ce que vous avez vu ce
soir on en rit était bien le plus petit
le plus bas en ruine et priori et bien
mais marcelo martins m c'est à la limite
il ya deux ou trois coups à mon avis pas
permis et dans l'interview y sont très à
kawa akwaba oui oui cela vous a été
d'accord lorsque l eau permet tait parce
que je pense oui
michel vous allez vraiment été gentil
comme tout devenir si je trouve quelque
chose en belgique vous avez trouvé oui
seulement alors maintenant il ya une
chose qu'il faut pas me de bordés s'est
parlé de la barre oui bah non parce que
parce que le tailleur je crois qu'il ya
deux ou trois qui vont pas être bien sûr
des contenus et donc un jour l'avare de
molière
oui ans ou mourir je pourrais le joueur
japonais - image et c'est toujours à
mogador usurpent le monologue au élaboré
oui donc pas vous parle je ne peux pas
parler que de moi voudrait dire un mot
quand même sur à cayenne reconduit aussi
bien à plat chaud et théo ces plans sont
planchon bonjour et chicago carmack et
aux rideaux succès à mogador énorme
metteur en scène voilà bien parfait bon
alors maintenant on va terminer
démission avec avec the cure et créé
voilà il vous pouvez il est encore temps
de faire un commentaire sur tout à
l'envers maintenant le cube c'est le
groupe parti points à les plus connues
dans le monde c'est à dire attendez je
vais vous dire exactement le titre de la
chanson s'il vous plaît il ya pas des
courants d'air je cours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]